like transferred oh yeah that's when
that's right after we transitioned from
heroine defend also which her body was
off heroin and shooting out
yeah not shooting up and so we found out
she was pregnant months it's one of
those things where you know I think it
was scary for the both of us
all right Matt and Megan welcome back
thank you so how long was it since we
last spoke probably about four five
words yeah yeah and you're begging you
were pregnant last time right mm-hmm
so what would happen with the pregnancy
so we actually before the pregnancy we
ended up going to see a case manager and
we got put on subutex which is a form of
suboxone and we saw a case manager so
that they could monitor it we both got
clean well except for this subutex yeah
and then about a week a week and a half
before Megan due date I went out to work
one one night and the the two or three
days prior she had been having really
bad contractions which they said we're
normal and so I left her to go to work
and as I was getting back I got a call
saying she had a seizure yeah so
two of our friends were with her at the
time thankfully they called the
ambulance
the ambulance came and picked her up and
she went to the hospital and she ended
up losing the baby she lost the baby
because she had what's known as
eclampsia and it's a condition that only
affects like five or six percent of
pregnancies
it has nothing related due to health
issues drug issues any any of that but
it became so severe that it was either
save the baby or save Megan and so Megan
was in a coma for two days she was a
nice to you for about five days and she
lost a baby yeah so sorry so it's been
you know really hard
yeah it we didn't have much support
before we before all of this to be you
know with a place to live where we have
no family here
so after it happened and Megan severely
down depressed we went back to using and
it was kind of one of those things where
it was kind of just an inevitable you
know we didn't seek any long-term
support for our issues and so it was
kind of a thing where it was inevitable
you know the stress of that was yeah
yeah it was kind of nervous overbearing
and you know I don't think it's really
hit either one of us fully yet but you
know I I I get very protective and I get
very emotional when people automatically
judge and think that she lost it because
she was using or because she was doing
this or that when that wasn't the case
at all you know and so just dealing with
that you know but since it's happened we
we haven't either
we haven't either of us talked to our
parents really either or or our families
since it happened and they've been
really concerned you know but since then
we've talked to them and we're working
on a plan to to get back home to where
she's from
and to try to get our lives back
together
I met Megan how are you holding up after
this how long ago was it this is about
three weeks ago the best I can do
you want to go home yeah back to your
family yeah I think that might be a good
first step just to give you a roof over
your head and a little bit of a little
more grounding yeah because you know she
needed a lot of support after that not
just I can give her and you know just
dealing with this stuff that we have to
deal with on a daily basis you know
that's already you know enough let alone
what happened to her
no it's so hard on the street yeah yuria
period that you know that that's to do
it to do with that it yeah is enough you
know and then for her to have to go
through that and you know like I said we
didn't do any long-term planning and so
after it happened it was just kind of
like you know spit you back out right to
where you were before and you know it's
hard it's hard to stay clean down there
it's it's hard to do the right thing
it's hard to to do anything normal down
here because of you know the
surroundings so
yeah unfortunately we went back to using
but I will say that I feel like it's
provided us a little glimpse of hope
because our families that kind of came
around us and you know they were they
were already wanting us to come home but
I think this kind of pushed all of us
together to where we we now can make
that happen we feel so I think that's
great and I just think down here after
what you just went through I can't see a
good outcome from that yeah you know
like living down here I mean you're
either only gonna end up dead or in jail
and that's just or spending your life
doing it forever which is bad yeah
that's not normal to us you know and
this isn't normal to us so you know but
you find yourself stuck down there you
find yourself just in a routine that it
doesn't become normal it just is routine
and what do you guys what do you think
people don't understand about addiction
because so many people would see you
hear your story you'd be like why the
hell would you choose to do this instead
of that and and I understand it very
differently I'm sure you guys do as well
that it's not about a decision to do
drugs it's not a choice yeah if it were
I obviously would have yeah you're
intelligent you would clearly decide
differently for your family for yourself
for your chart yeah yeah I don't know
our parents they see addiction the same
way a lot of people do of it being a
choice and yes it is being it is
ultimately a choice but you get stuck in
like the rabbit hole you know like it
really brings you into a place and where
use your inner being into a place that
it's not as easy as just saying alright
I'm gonna stop today or all right this
is not what you know like I'm not going
to do this tomorrow because
unfortunately we use opiates we get sick
you know alcoholics get sick you know
and that's just a fact of life so
getting clean isn't as easy as going to
sleep for a few days and we'll be back
to normal you know it's really actually
going through a process and really
detoxing our bodies off of these
substances too you know we regain a
normal seat you know and usually it
takes me about three weeks to a month to
fully get back to where I'm sleeping
alright feeling okay when I wake up and
you know like to when you're it when
you're used actively using to think
ahead about that that month of just pure
torture and hating your life feeling
miserable you know it doesn't sound good
and a lot of time at addicts can't look
past today you know and so to look
forward maybe a month and a half or two
months to where your life is normal
again that's a lot of times too far
ahead for addicts to to even have hope
you know so you know it's just it's it's
really hard and I don't think that we
could do it without each other or our
families you know because we've we've
been sick with this life a long
we've wanted to leave here a long time
ago but I don't think if it was for our
families you know really you know
everyday attempting to get us back home
that it would ever happen and it's sad
to say that you know a lot of people do
just die down here they come down here
from normal families or a normal life
sometimes and they get stuck and they
pass away and it's it's sad bigoted how
are you going
what's your mental state at this point
you feel any guilt over this of course
yeah yeah shame it's hard for a mother
right mm-hmm
yeah and like I said that's when I get
protected because you know like when she
when someone says something or something
said or I can feel it you know I can
feel the guilt and the shame from her
and so that's when I get emotional and I
speak up because you know this thing
that happened is it wasn't because of
drugs or health issues or anything you
know it's just something that sometimes
rarely happens and it happened to her
and it wasn't caught before beforehand
and she almost lost her life you know
she was dead she was in a coma for two
days so I think people need to reserve
their judgment and try to look at other
people's feelings because she's already
going through a lot she's already
feeling a lot and instead of
digging into what happened or why it
happened just try to be there for the
person that it happened to know I think
I think the majority of people on social
media don't understand much of anything
ya know a lot a lot of people don't
period because they are very you know
people are nosy people and people are
want to be into other people's lives
that's why they watch like the Real
Housewives and Kardashians and stuff
because they're interested in other
people's lives
and they would rather know what's going
on then you know how the person's
feeling or how the person is doing and
you know so those questions aren't asked
of Megan how are you you know it's
instead it's well what happened well was
it because of drugs
you know like and yeah that's just not
what she you know I think I think losing
a child for her mother to be is
tremendously painful and then I'm doing
it in Megan the situation makes it more
complicated more difficult even if it is
a farm right right it just complicates
the whole and she you know we were are
I'm sure it's just human nature to take
some of it you know you feel guilty
about it feel shame and all that all the
other emotions that come up even if it
is something that is so hard for anyone
yeah you know and it even makes me
question myself like what was it because
of the drugs
like if we were doing something
different like what did have happened
and you know like Megan and I can ask
ourselves that a million a million times
but like the outcome is still the same
it happened and you know hopefully Megan
I can just take this and learn from it
and farther down the line we can or when
we're ready to have a child we can
you're still young yeah and she she
actually after she lost the baby they
gave her the implant the birth control
implant which I think was a really smart
thing for Megan to do you know it was
very irresponsible of us to even bring
in to this life someone else when were
not even capable of taking care of
ourselves and so although it was a
devastating thing what happened and I
wish I could change it I wish we could
change it you know we should have taken
the precautionary measures beforehand to
where that wasn't that that couldn't be
an outcome
so now she has the implant she can have
the implant I think for as long as she
wants the two years so you know I think
maybe later down the line once we get
our lives together once were sober
around our family you know we can try
again but I think it was very a very
responsible decision that she made you
know during a really difficult time to
to do that so your plan is to go back
home yeah we could be doing that um I
don't know we honestly would like to get
out of here today if we could
but there's there's also the reasons why
we can't go home right away
we don't have IDs you have 1090 to
travel on a plane
get on the bus to get on the train so we
have to take care of some things before
that happens but you know I think that
it's at least now going in a positive
direction because
you know at least my parents are now
looking at it more as we don't care what
it takes to just get you guys home we're
willing to do that you know like they
don't care what the details are what
what's been going on they're not having
any more questions about that they just
want to know how can we help now which
is good because you know when we have to
start answering questions about the past
that's when we tend to show up and so
you're working now I'm not right now
I've just kind of been with Megan
hugging her until you said you were
working yeah I was just working like odd
jobs but yeah I look so when that
happened I had left for like three or
four hours to go make some money with a
friend and I was actually at the train
station downtown LA when it happened so
I was maybe a mile away from Winnick I
literally walked up on the platform or
outside I walked outside and got the
phone call like maybe just had a seizure
like and I was really not told to
anything other than that and so yeah it
was very very very scary
very sorry about the baby you guys and I
hope you guys get your way back home
that's a Pennsylvania mm-hmm yeah so I
think that we're gonna try to like maybe
go see my family first and then because
our ultimate plan is to go be with her
family
she has a large family eight brothers
three sisters so you know she has a lot
of support there and that's what she
needs and I know once we get away from
this that it's gonna really kind of hit
us harder and you know maybe hit her
harder and so I want her to have the
support that she needs to work she
doesn't make any severe choice or you
know have any severe consequences from
those choices so I'm getting home as
soon as possible yeah all right you guys
thank you so much for coming in yeah
thank you and good luck with everything
you're still young so you have lots of
time to just sort this out and start a
family and all that kind of stuff yeah
thank you very much I really appreciate
it thanks for coming in again thank you
[Music]
okay
you